maybe being in a relationship with kanye
for you know a decade and someone that
absolutely didn't care about likability
factor or what any perception of him was
as long as he was true to himself
that taught me so much in the best way
kim kardashian west opens up about how
her estranged husband kanye west changed
her life he's just the most genuine
person the 40 year old superstar was
this week's guest on the we are
supported by podcast hosted by kristen
bell and monica padman where she gave
credit to kanye for helping her find her
authentic self
i used to care so much about being
likable maybe being in a relationship
with kanye for you know a decade and
someone that absolutely didn't care
about likability factor or what any
perception of him was as long as he was
true to himself
that taught me so much in the best way
as long as i'm myself and as long as i'm
doing it the way that i want to do like
you have one life and you're living it
for you
that taught me to just i think be more
confident in myself and truly not care
as much
of what other people thought on the show
kim shares how she overcame her
people-pleaser mentality and how she
came to terms with being the quote [ __ ]
of the week on keeping up with the
kardashians while it was airing and she
says she owes it to kanye
i used to be such a people pleaser
and then when i got to just
learn to please myself no matter what
that meant to other people still being
mindful still being respectful still
being cautious of like other people's
feelings and emotions around me
i would never want to offend anyone but
just being myself first
i think was something that i learned
over time
kim filed for divorce from the rapper in
february of this year but the former
couple seemed to be on good terms
despite their split
kim supported him at his recent
listening events for his new and deeply
personal album donda which he is gearing
up to release
[Applause]
kim went to both events with friends and
family including sister chloe kim rocked
a balenciaga catsuit with a matching
face mask and a long ponytail to the
second event i don't know what's going
to top that kim and kanye's kids were
all in attendance at both events showing
a united front improving that
unbreakable family bond him and i have
been best friends for a really long time
and just been in each other's lives and
known each other for a long time and i
can honestly say
i think that's just a really good
foundation for a good relationship a
source recently told et that the two are
doing great at successfully co-parenting
their four children north saint chicago
and psalm
[Music]